[Musica]
[Applauso]
io dico parole sbagliate
tutti noi lo facciamo
eccolo appena fatto avete sentito la mia
seconda frase era sbagliata
sì perché siamo uomini e donne
quindi nonostante come dice dacia
maraini la nostra grammatica sia
misogina io voglio essere corretta
quindi
tutti e tutte noi lo facciamo
a ma anche la mia prima frase era
sbagliata e sì perché
non esistono parole sbagliate ma
soltanto parole che messe in un
determinato ordine detta in un
determinato modo
con una determinata intenzione fanno sì
che ci siano degli effetti sugli altri a
cui non avevamo pensato che non avremmo
mai voluto
e che comunque
provocano sugli altri un qualcosa di
spiacevole di
antipatico di non rispettoso a volte di
dannoso addirittura di violento
e non soltanto le parole
lo sappiamo il linguaggio è qualcosa che
ha a che fare con il nostro corpo e
quindi anche quelli che sono i nostri
gesti le azioni movimenti la postura del
nostro corpo o l'espressione del nostro
viso i nostri sguardi il tono della
nostra voce insomma tutte le immagini
ei suoni che produciamo
tutti i nostri linguaggi sono portatori
di messaggi
e di intenzioni
io sono convinta che sia successo anche
a voi avete presente quando
cerchiamo di comunicare qualcosa e siamo
convinti che la nostra intenzione sia
chiara e invece il nostro interlocutore
prende la cosa all'esatto opposto avete
presente anche succede molto spesso
quando mando i messaggini su whatsapp
succede anche a voi ecco allora io penso
di fare la spiritosa normando un
messaggino ironico e l'altra persona lo
prende sul serio e magari si arrabbia
anche si offende allora lì ho capito che
conviene sempre mettere vicino una
faccina un e moggi allora magari per far
capire che deve essere letto in maniera
ironica ci metto quello a me piace molto
quello che strizza l'occhiolino con la
linguetta fuori avete presente quello lì
funziona però con certe altre persone la
linguetta fuori non va bene allora dico
metto lo smile è un classico quello
funziona con tutti
magari per essere più chiara se voglio
far capire che proprio ci si deve ridere
sopra allora magari ci metto quello in
lol quello con la bocca aperta che si
sganascia dalle risate con le lacrimucce
che escono dagli occhi insomma metto
faccine su faccine e faccio un disastro
eppure noi siamo sempre molto attenti
nell'esprimere il nostro pensiero siamo
molto concentrati su noi stessi e
cerchiamo sempre di non tradire il
nostro pensiero io lo sto facendo adesso
in questo momento sto cercando di
trovare le parole giuste ei gesti giusti
per esprimere quello che c'è in testa ma
manca l'altra metà della comunicazione
il destinatario
noi non pensiamo mai a come gli altri
possano recepire il messaggio
invece siamo veramente molto bravi ad
adattare il nostro linguaggio alle
situazioni in questo veniamo addestrati
fin da piccini ci dicono che non
dobbiamo dire le parolacce nelle
situazioni formali io stasera non ve lo
dirò ci dicono che bisogna essere
gentili con gli estranei
oppure con le persone da cui possiamo
ottenere qualcosa in questo siamo
bravissimi tutti e tutte noi lo facciamo
chi vuole fare bella figura
chi vuole evitare un incidente
diplomatico
chi vuole vendere qualcosa
anche se stesso a un colloquio di lavoro
ad esempio oppure chi vuole ottenere la
stima del proprio interlocutore o anche
semplicemente vuole piacere a qualcuno a
qualcuna con cui è uscito la sera
però
quando non stiamo così attenti quando
abbassiamo la guardia
ecco che arriva un demone che si
impossessa di noi e ci fa scappare via
cose che non avremmo mai voluto farci
scappare
qualche esempio alla guida finestrino
abbassato qualcuno ci taglia la strada
ed ecco che urli urliamo contro tutti
gli epiteti di cui siamo a conoscenza
improperi che non vi ripeterò
perché sono stata tirata su bene
oppure
ad esempio l'altro giorno ero in coda
alla cassa al supermercato davanti a me
c'era un signore di colore con cui ho
cominciato a scambiare qualche parola
dandogli del tu ma perché
oppure voglio indicare un mio amico una
ragazza dall'altra parte della strada
quella la quella l'acqua no no non
quella l'altra quella città
oppure a casa c'è una persona a me cara
che si rivolge dicendo che vuole
parlarmi vuole chiedermi qualcosa e io
dico sì sì sì
dimmi dimmi pure e intanto lo sguardo
resta incollato al telefonino cellulare
oppure voi uomini
siete davvero molto gentili a farci un
sacco di complimenti sul nostro fisico
sul nostro aspetto esteriore
grazie
alle volte un po fuori luogo
quale luogo
sul luogo di lavoro ad esempio ecco lì
anche no grazie diteci in caso che siamo
bravi se siamo bravi
oppure
ecco il luogo dove il demone si scatena
sono i social lì noi non guardiamo in
faccia nessuno nessuno ci guarda negli
occhi il demone s'impossessa di noi
ed ecco che gli altri diventano il
nemico da annientare
ma perché è così difficile
cercare un altro modo per dirlo o meglio
ci rendiamo conto che esiste un altro
modo per dirlo
o meglio ancora
perché cercare un altro modo per dirlo
per rispetto degli altri per esempio
per evitare di fare del male per esempio
perché le parole esattamente come le
azioni hanno conseguenze le parole sono
azioni
e possono fare del male
per esempio
inoltre le parole
esattamente come le azioni ci
rappresentano le parole e le azioni
gesti eccetera
sono
ambasciatrici del mio pensiero
quindi la forma che assumono deve
assomigliarmi io devo fare in modo di
trovare le parole che mi esprimano amy
rappresentino al meglio
se io dico qualcosa di spiacevole
non faccio soltanto del male a qualcuno
ma sarò io una persona spiacevole
se le mie parole e le mie azioni sono
aggressive la mia aggressività farà del
male a qualcuno ma renderà me una
persona aggressiva
è questo quello che voglio
il punto è che a volte non ce ne
rendiamo conto oppure ce ne rendiamo
conto però magari è troppo tardi e
magari il danno ormai è fatto
si è faticoso lo so
la relazione è faticosa
il rispetto è faticoso tutto quello che
ci rende uomini e donne migliori
non è gratuito
e quindi che facciamo
rinunciamo
qual è la strategia
migliore
almeno per provarci
qui si devono portare delle idee
la mia strategia è talmente semplice da
sembrare banale e mettersi nei panni
degli altri
talmente banale che rischia di essere
sottovalutata qui da voi adesso
eppure fa parte del nostro quotidiano
è alla base del mio lavoro
è alla base del lavoro di attori e
attrici
e non fingono no
nonostante quello che si pensi non c'è
niente di più vero di quello che fanno
gli attori e le attrici
si mettono nei panni degli altri
in situazioni altre
provano empatia
l'empatia è quella cosa che quando sei
davanti a qualcuno che sta piangendo che
si riempiono gli occhi di lacrime e ti
si stringe la gola
adesso
se io fossi una neuroscienziata
vi farei un bellissimo discorso sui
neuroni specchio
ma ahimè non sono una neuroscienziata
e quindi
niente discorso scientifico ma vi
propongo un esercizio
sull'immaginario
propedeutica dell'attore
ecco qua un bel limone giallo
morbido
e profumato
ho anche un coltello con la seghetta
chi vuole può fare questo esercizio ad
occhi chiusi soltanto i più arditi
attenzione
con la seghetta cominciò a incidere
la buccia del limone
ecco che arrivò fino alla polpa
il limone si taglia a metà
la polpa comincia a lasciar cadere
qualche goccia di succo sul tagliere
ecco che l'ho tagliato in due belle metà
ne prendo una
e molto profumato
adesso provo a strizzare
il mezzo limone
ed
avete visto le goccioline
spruzzandolo il succo del limone
esce e copre tutta la metà della polpa
ne esce tantissimo le gocce cadono sulla
mia mano
o
è aspro e dolce allo stesso tempo
adesso
ditemi
alzando la mano chi di voi approvato
almeno un pochino di acquolina in bocca
ma bravissimi bravissime potreste fare
gli attori e le attrici complimenti non
me l'aspettavo
bene allora possiamo andare avanti con
un altro esercizio sull'immaginario e
proviamo a metterci nei panni degli
altri
a questo punto avrei voluto farvi vedere
quattro fotografie ma ci sono problemi
di copyright quindi continuiamo con gli
esercizi sull'immaginario ve ne faccio
immaginare prima fotografia
è una sfilata di moda primavera estate
2022 del dello stilista marco rambaldi
chi vuole fare meno fatica lo cerca sul
motore di ricerca del telefonino e lo
vede
lui è uno stilista molto attento alla
democrazia umana e libero completamente
libero dagli stereotipi della bellezza
quindi i suoi modelli e le sue modelle
sono persone comuni persone che hanno
tutti i difetti come ognuno di noi
una di queste la modella curvy giulia
all leonardo
sfilava in passerella in una sua
sfilata con una canottierina fucsia di
maglina piuttosto attillata e poi con
una gonna in maglina lilla piuttosto
lunga con un po di spacco sul lato
niente riscontro bene questa immagine è
diventata virale ed è stata pesantemente
attaccata sui social
accusandola di indecenza e
continuando nei commenti con epiteti
pesanti e volgari nei suoi confronti
bene proviamo a metterci nei panni di
questa modella
qual è la sua colpa
che cosa può aver provato
cioè il problema erano i chili di troppo
per questo era stata ritenuta indecente
che cosa sentito
leggendo quegli attacchi volgari nei
suoi confronti mentre stava facendo
semplicemente il suo lavoro
seconda fotografia questa è facile
perché la conoscete sicuramente tutti
2009 pittsburgh g20 il nostro ex
presidente del consiglio silvio
berlusconi al cospetto dei coniugi obama
silvio berlusconi davanti alla signora
obama
viene ritratto in questa fotografia
esattamente con questa espressione
se noi mettiamo insieme una dietro
l'altra tutte le fotografie e le
fotografie che sono state scattate in
quella occasione
più o meno possiamo ricostruire il gesto
che era qualcosa del genere
e lo sguardo non era dritto negli occhi
della signora obama ma 50 centimetri più
in giù
al di là di come siamo stati
rappresentati
immaginiamo che cosa può aver provato la
signora obama in quel momento al di là
del sorriso di circostanza
pensate che l'abbia fatto piacere essere
trattata così si sarà sentita lusingata
da quel gesto
terza fotografia
2007 e la nota coppia di stilisti
italiani
fa uscire sul mercato una campagna
pubblicitaria che
inquadrava in questa fotografia
alcuni modelli molto molto belli una
donna distesa a terra sulla schiena con
le gambe nude piegate e aperte davanti a
lei un uomo a torso nudo in ginocchio
che le blocca i polsi con le mani dietro
di lui altri tre uomini uno a torso nudo
1 con la camicia aperta e un altro che
guarda la scena la campagna è stata
tolta dal mercato perché alludeva e
istigava alla violenza sessuale di
gruppo
proviamo a metterci nei panni di una
donna vittima di violenza sessuale
apre una rivista e trova questa
fotografia
cosa può provare
perché dove comprare quei james
quarta e ultima fotografia
questa è di un famosissimo fotografo
lucas jackson è stata scattata nelle
strade di new york dove tre ragazze
vestite alla moda con una posa molto
modaiola si fanno fotografare da un
altro fotografo
accanto a loro non c'è una vetrina alla
moda un monumento un'opera d'arte no ma
un senzatetto
con la barba lunga sporco e vestito di
stracci
proviamo a metterci nei panni di
quest'uomo
il linguaggio dei gesti della postura
la prossemica di questa foto
rivela una totale inconsapevolezza del
fatto che lì è presente una persona che
può essere ferita semplicemente dal
fatto di essere ignorata
il linguaggio discriminatorio non
inclusivo aggressivo
nasce essenzialmente da un atteggiamento
noi
contro di loro
chiunque siamo noi e chiunque siano loro
mettersi nei panni degli altri
disinnesca questa modalità
mi è stato chiesto di parlare del
linguaggio come una delle nuove muse
le nuove muse sono le nuove fonti di
ispirazione le nuove forme per esprimere
la bellezza
ecco io penso che la musa del linguaggio
oggi debba chiamarsi empatia
[Applauso]